pas une marque sur le dos laissez-vous servir le
plat laissez plus mince
sortez d'ici mais comment allez-vous mesdames
et messieurs vous savez ce qu'est un cruller
c'est un très bon système d'argent de vous
ce soir désolé et j'espère que nous avons un ange
le spectacle en premier  s'il vous plaît Charlie il y a sur les
onglets ouais Oh sanglots vous ne le faites pas Oh
fantastique
mesdames et messieurs maintenant je dois penser que c'est une
très belle chanson pour vous la chanson est
marmonner maintenant mesdames et messieurs et
tout le monde dit marmonner d'accord une
fois de plus s'il vous plaît gagnant mambo mambo sapeur
cavalier  pour